[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
avec un sommet assez chargé on va parler
notamment de tous les scandales et qui
apparaissent dans le domaine du sport et
pour cela je suis ravi d'accueillir
pierre chevallier bons chevaux bourgeois
patrice night droite mais vous avez une
grande expérience dans le milieu du
sport une vingtaine d'années
d'expérience dans le domaine d'ô de
vente du rugby du golf vous avez entre
des équipes vous avez joué vous même
vous avez beau vous jouez encore et vous
connaissez extrêmement bien le milieu du
sport et les scandales et qui le secoue
évidemment vous interpelle on va en
parler pendant quelques instants à côté
de vous jean baptiste du club bonjour
patrie ça va bien très bien merci
alors vous êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
tandis que hans herren bezina duclair et
maître de conférences à l'université de
rouen
c'est cela et on s'est dit aussi à
sciences po oui et je pense que vous
allez très bien tout à fait c'est parce
qu'on va d'ailleurs dans le domaine ce
que sexuel universités on en parlera
peut-être avec sont pas encore sorties
pas concernés on est en sécurité et je
serai là je dis bonjour bonjour ça va
bien vous êtes éditeur et vous avez bien
raison public formidable travail et je
pense que c'est tout à fait d'actualité
ces fantassins c'est une seule la vie
des gens le sachent il est sorti ya
mais on va le sortir en poche c'est pour
ça qu'il a très bien marché est là et
c'est vraiment d'actualité sachant cela
devrait être imposé à chaque gilet jaune
pour réfléchir un peu et puis tout le
monde mais pas qu'aux gilet jaune mais
en tout cas où gens qui savent lire ces
noms c'est vraiment bien c'est amoral
immoral et sur le travail c'est vraiment
une très belle reine travailler tu ne
dis pas ça s'assume et eu c'est vrai un
travail lent parle de pénibilité là ils
mettent la barre assez compliqué alors
on va on va commencer par ct par
l'événement ce qui est l'événement s'est
en effet les les scandales sexuels qui
qui trouble le milieu du sport et
notamment dans tous les sports on n'en
parle pas beaucoup du patinage
artistique mais c'est vrai dans tous les
sports c'est l'événement alors c'est
vrai que les révélations en révélations
ces révélations de scandales sexuels
d'attouchements de viol dans le mythe du
juste pas je vois je veux commencer avec
boo pierre chevalier on a l'impression
que il y avait des secrets qui était
bien gardé que personne ne sait dire et
là il suffit qu'une personne parler mais
en plein de choses terribles d'ailleurs
balle et c'est ça ressemble au phénomène
planétaire maintenant du hashtag be to
make
j'ai démarré aux états unis et qui va
d'une certaine manière pour le bien de
tous libérer la parole dans le sport on
a effectivement 7,7
cette bombe qui vient de sortir sur la
fédération française des sports de glace
mais on a on a tous les fronts pour se
doucher d'un coup un certain nombre de
voiles à un certain nombre de langues
qui se délient et des gens des gens qui
se mettent à qui se met à parler et qui
m mettre au grand jour ce qu'on peut
effectivement appelé scandale sévices
tout le tout le vocabulaire et le champ
lexical de l'innommable quasiment dans
et tous les sports tous les sports sont
effectivement effectivement touché par
les avants ont discuté un petit peu
avant l'émission parlez vous même vous
avez travaillé beaucoup dans le golfe
notamment il ya eu il ya des équipes qui
sont passés presque inaperçus
je crois que c'est ce qui est vraiment
révélateur c'est le silence l'omerta qui
a qui a vraiment duré et depuis depuis
une vingtaine ou une trentaine d'années
dans le secteur golf effectivement que
je connais bien puisque dès qu'il y a
des qui lie à sport il y as formation
italien écoles il y à des jeunes publics
parfois depuis depuis l'âge de 5 ans par
exemple pour le pour le golf
et effectivement on a eu on a eu la
l'effroi de constater que certains
certains encadrant certains certains
dirigeants de clubs ou des encadrants
des écoles de golf par exemple avait été
pris dans la tourmente et le problème
qui se pose c'est que non seulement ils
ont été pris dans la tourmente mais ils
ont été repris ça veut dire que il ya eu
des condamnations et plusieurs fois de
suite ça veut dire que trois fois dans
le secteur gulf sur sur les golf auquel
je pense et ça veut dire aussi qu'il ya
eu il ya eu trois fois de trop les uns
plus il faudra fermer les yeux et on a
fermé les yeux il a été condamné et il
n'y a pas eu de suivi et on en parlera
sûrement c'est notamment maintenant le
croisement des fichiers et de ski de ce
qui se fait justement pour prévenir ce
type d'événement jusqu'à maintenant ça
ne s'était pas fait c'est à dire que en
toute impunité un homme ou une femme
pris dans des dents des dans des
scandales sexuels pouvez re exercer dans
les arts du canada soient bénévoles soit
soit salarié et c'est ça c'est ça aussi
peut-être à nuance dont on parlerait
aussi c'est la nuance entre le bénévolat
et les et les contrats de travail et les
points de contrôle qui sont pas les
mêmes absolument le fait que les gens
qui étaient soupçonnés ou qui était qui
m'étais pris la main sur le com comme
dans le sport ce qui est arrivé dans le
patinage artistique
mais il ya trois éléments qui sont
importants me semble-t-il c'est d'abord
que il ya entre les entraîneurs ou les
encadrants et les jeunes sportifs il ya
d'abord un phénomène d'autorité donc
c'est important
il ya une proximité du corps puisqu'on
montrons touche
forcément dans le sport et puis il ya le
fait quand même que et ce à tous les
spécialistes le savent c'est à dire que
tous les gens qui sont enfin un peu
pervers peuvent être attirés par des
milieux où il ya des jeunes gens des
anneaux jeune fille
ces trois évêques ont fait descendre ces
trois éléments faute donne des choses
c'est assez terrible le premier le
premier puisque vous avez cité peut-être
le plus embêtant c'est à dire des
autorités et je dirais l'influencent
l'influencé qu'exercent les entraîneurs
les dirigeants lorsqu'il s'agit
notamment
c'est le cas dans les temps la
fédération des sports de glace de la
route vers le haut niveau c'est à dire
que c'était pour certains quasiment
automatique
si vous voulez percée dans le haut
niveau si vous allez si tu veux aller le
plus haut possible
être championne de france championne
d'europe il va falloir il va falloir en
gros que tu me vois que tu que tu sois
gentil avec mon dieu évidemment je
l'étais guillemat des guillemets partout
mais cette influence la des entraîneurs
en faisant peser la pression des
résultats la compétition leur donner
cette espèce de jose pas l'appeler de
droit de droit à exercer les plus les
plus bas instincts et dont l'influencé
sur joua plan derrière il ya c'était
effectivement dans le dans le sport et
la concentration et le fait que la
promiscuité le fait qu'on soit plusieurs
plusieurs des jeunes et autres il ya
l'avant il ya d'après entraînement il ya
l'avant et l'après match
oui ça donne ça donne mal au
malheureusement des idées avec des idées
à certains l'abandon des parents aussi
et que tout on n'est que vous avez pas
bien la complicité voilà ce que le mot
est fort mais parfois j'en sais c'est
vrai dans le sport c'est peut être vrai
dans d'autres cas ça ça rappelle louis
d'autres univers a fermé la première
affaire polanski je vais vers le le père
de cette fille de 15 ans qui apporte
n'ai pas d'autres mots qu'a apporté
apporte sa fille presque on off rendre
le soir jack nicholson et à polanski il
sait très bien que c'était une ville un
espace des partouzes et défonce de
drogue 24 heures sur 24 il dépose sa
fille eut dit genre effet rhj est de
manhatan même temps je veux dire c'est
ne pouvait pas soupçonner aussi il ya
des parents qui pavent or confiance
aussi dans le cadre mans
non mais ça prend une certaine vigilance
aussi c'est exactement des nuls et des
gamins qui a mené les parents de liam ne
s'est pas levée de l'année essentielle
mon avis mais non mais on peut on peut
pas d'être sous lui on n'est pas en
parler parce que c'est une confiance de
confiance envers l'encadrement et son
club comme vous mais de l'école en est
sorti fin à priori vous faites confiance
à ceux qui leur ont scandé les yeux
fermés et fort heureusement ça reste et
il faut que ça reste la portion congrue
et c'est une question de confiance de
des enfants des parents est ce que les
enfants et les parents se parlent quel
que soit le contexte quelles que soient
les quels que soient les problèmes
après les buts john mais au début ne
vous l'a dit dès que dès que quelqu'un
parle et c'est moi c'est aussi un peu ce
qui me choque c'est que on a
l'impression que dans ce domaine très
réservé est effectivement très très
compliqué la moindre parole de la
moindre personne vos autorités vos
jugements et la personne en face les qui
est nommé et les forcément coupable la
présomption d'innocence n'existe plus du
tout dans ce domaine en atout c'est vrai
qu'on l'avait vu avec son ballon que
même mis tous voila mais parce que c'est
peut-être une parole qui a été mon frère
après un ballon mal est fait c'est à
dire que le moment empêché pendant des
années que maintenant elles remontent à
la surface est évidemment un coton côte
quand on accuse quelqu'un d'avoir volé
une mobylette il ya quand même une
enquête a comme un truc même si on
retrouve la mobilité chez la personne ya
quand même des avocats il ya comme la
jussie dialogueront sert à rien dans les
journaux on change le nom du mec qui
volent et la mobylette et là pas du tout
simplement en complément jeu tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que dit jean charles et
on a notamment la ministre qui a demandé
la démission du patron du crédit nagent
et qui décide ensuite de mener une
enquête dans l'ordre des choses en
mayenne enquête et le cacher on appelle
à la démission donc je leur accorde
jahren franchement qu'on parle d'
influence mais on devrait parler pouvoir
en réalité parce que je pense que si ça
se passe dans le milieu du sport que ça
se passe dans le milieu du cinéma que
c'est peut-être en train de se passer
dans le milieu du politique
c'est notamment parce qu'on est dans des
milieux où
ou comme vous lisiez un chantage qui
peut se créer très facilement parce
qu'il ya du pouvoir parce qu'il ya des
petits droit qui peuvent amener certains
à du coup créer ce climat dans l'oise en
quoi je crois que c'est même pas
tellement là la confiance qu'on peut
avoir en un entraîneur ou quelque chose
mais c'est cette idée qui a une rançon
dont quelque part derrière la gloire et
le milieu du cinéma dont tu faisais par
allen est à mon avis vraiment un peu
identique dans ces idées là il ya une
deuxième idée qui est celle ci est une
nuance quand même à mon avis il y avait
mes yeux du cdma tous ces milieux là il
ya un quota petit côté sulfureux qui a
toujours existé dans le sport il y avait
quand même confiance et il me semble
enfin une confiance totale notamment des
parents
quand vous mettez votre enfant au sport
totalement confiante pour sait pas qui
va se passer des choses c'est l'ubs
l'appareil peut-être de mettre son
enfant au point n'est besoin que de
l'amener au championnat du monde alors
représenter la faible hauteur de très
hautes ans qu'on parle ici de choses qui
sont très resserrée et comme vous lit
d'ailleurs avec des périodes de temps
qui font qu'on vit ensemble dans des
dans des conditions qui sont tout à fait
particulière donc donc il ya tout ça
aussi et je crois que d'ailleurs on
parlait de la jeunesse et ses délits là
c'est pas pareil que quand on vole une
mobylette justement c'est à dire que
malheureusement la parole se libère très
longtemps après et moi je pense et le
problème du temps qu'on rencontre ici
c'est qu'on a des infractions qui sont
souvent prescrite ou alors la parole qui
se libèrent et qui du coup va amener à
aa a condamné d'office une personne qui
n'a pas le temps de se défendre mais
parce que en quelque sorte la victime se
met à parler tellement tard que du coup
il ya un espèce d'effet de voilà j'ai
envie de dire la poudre qui fait que
tout le monde va se libérer en même
temps et c'est vrai qu'au niveau
judiciaire moi ça me gêne un petit peu
mais au moins on a en effet sociologie
qui consiste
limiter la contraire rouvrir la parole
et à permettre que d'autres victimes
puissent maintenant considérer que ça
n'est plus un acquis et changer des
méthodes s'échanger aussi des
consciences mais au niveau du droit au
niveau de la justice
c'est vrai qu'on met dans les abîmes et
dans un temps étudié aussi j'avais
raison parler de parler de pouvoir et
j'ajoute le le terme de pression
pression du résultat des pressions qu'il
y a eu pendant des années sur le fait de
ne pas parler de la libération de la
parole oui ça va être une déflagration
là la pression qui est qui et qui est
exercée s'est exercée par exemple sur
des sur dd des anciennes championnes je
vais pas leur faire l'enfant de dire
vieille mais des anciennes championnes
comme isabelle demongeot au tennis ou
veulent de moi je les avais floreani
qu'elle essaye de les lancer la lergue
est maintenant attendue donc elle peut
être à nouveau entendue sur les
pressions qu'elle a subi à partir du
moment où elle a levé le doigt en disant
c'est pas normal et les pressions que
les uns et les autres ont fait peser sur
elle pour qu'elle se la ferme
ça reste vraiment sous le silence où le
silence est que ce soit avec sa fille
nice par devenir prescrivent pas ce
qu'il y ait une optique de groupe
finalement c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que l'on n'a pas affaire à un
délire individuel finalement c'est tout
un milieu qui se sont attaqué quand une
affaire sort bien celle ci et c'est ça
qui est intéressant de faire bouger je
pense qu'il s'agisse de bousculer un
petit peu les principes du droit pénal
malheureusement on peut tous en être
déçu présomption d'innocence et je
rajouterais secret de l'instruction
c'est vrai que est prescrite sucre
défendre il faut se défier sur l'avenue
prescription parce que saisir si c'est
important parce que les cours qu'il il
faudrait il faudrait enlever les
prescriptions
je crois que ce serait une très mauvaise
sur la question des délits et des crimes
sexuels la question méritait quand même
parce que c'est vrai que dans la dans le
schéma de la victime et de la libération
de la parole on n'est pas du tout dans
des infractions qui qui peuvent
s'inscrire dans un temps identique à
celui d'une victime d'un vol d'un effet
pervers à la prescription sévère que la
parole se libérant effectivement
traitants etc
n'importe qui c'est facile jugement
balançant révélation scène aux
révélations du type qui est qui est
visée ne peut pas défendre ce cas pas
dans le piège là rien du tout donc on
balance son nom le type est finie et
voilà c'est terminé le l'opinion
publique et a jugé abbaoui ce type est
un porc on sera jamais c'est vrai ou pas
vrai la femme a balancé son nom et c'est
fini
donc quel est le type il est
définitivement cuit donc c est ce qu ils
complètent dangereux dans le débat qu'on
a justement c'est qu'il ne s'agit plus
de pouvoir effectivement que d'autorité
et donc pouvoir c'est-à-dire une
possibilité d'évoluer de grandir dans
une carrière que ce soit dans le monde
du cinéma dans monde du sport etc
bon alors là les problèmes dont on parle
sont plutôt appliquer au mieux de
l'enfance donc il est difficile de
penser la chose disons qu'il ya bien sûr
mais c'est vrai que si on transpose le
débat à l'échelle des adultes
et plutôt une guerre au phénomène mis
tout bas qui dit possibilité d'évoluer
d'obtenir quelque chose de plus dans une
carrière professionnelle dit aussi
possibilité de se dire bah je vais
donner mon corps et puis ensuite par
hypothèse lorsqu'ensuite liens îliens il
ya un scandale je vais dire que
finalement j'ai agi par voie d'autorité
sous contrainte et c est là je pense
qu'il faut faire le bien le départ entre
l'hypothèse on est dans une situation de
contrainte qui fait qu'on se sent
emprisonné avec des ressorts
psychologiques complexes qui font qu
effectivement on se sent comme vraiment
violenté et puis ceux qui vont au
contraire abusé enfin utiliser pardon
leur corps comme une monnaie d échange
et là on est dans un autre système je
pense notamment à la ferme weinstein là
il ya une des plaignantes qui est mis en
cause justement parce que il ya des
échanges qui montrent que elle a une
relation avec lui s'il paraît presque
amoureuse en tout cas très intéressé il
ya une deuxième une deuxième affaire
dans les sports de glace qui vient de
sortir dans le dans la dans le sillage
de ce qu'a dénoncé sarah abitbol avec
justement 7,7 cette monnaie des changes
où on faisait comprendre à cette jeune
que si elle voulait progresser et percé
il fallait que il fallait qu'on trouve
sur les questions prostituée et se
prostitue mois et à l'ego du tout ni
moins que la mer et donc c'était un test
là c'était ce que disait jean seb tout à
l'heure c'était enfin on appelait en
tout cas la complicité de la mer
c'est toute la difficulté de ce cénacle
du crime sexuel c'est que déjà c'est
quelque chose de difficile à avouer
c'est quelque chose qui est protégé
généralement du côté de ce pont qu'on a
peur de banon c'est ce pourquoi c'est
bien que la parole se libère mais on a
de l'autre côté tout un problème de
preuve
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
vous avez affaire à deux personnes dans
un endroit qui évidemment par principe
n'est pas filmé ce qu'on appelle lé
secret de l'alcôve et bien le droit
rencontre ses limites c'est que ça va
être la parole de l'un contre la parole
de l'autre rencontre adulte et on s'en
contre adultes donc il ya aussi toute
ces
toutes ces idées de toute façon même si
je parle ça ne mènera à rien etc qui ont
conduit à ce que beaucoup de femmes
finalement on arrive a estimé qu'il
valait voilà il ya un gardien
donc je pense que même si on vit un
moment un peu conflictuelle avec toutes
ces affaires qui sortent d'un coup au
moins on peut peut-être essayer de
changer le paradigme en disant parler à
temps pour qu'il puisse y avoir aussi
avoir un débat contradictoire de l'autre
société d'ailleurs de manière assez
assez collective dans un sport qui
pourrait qui pourrait laisser penser que
ce genre de d'affaires n'arrive pas le
rugby dans le ring je connais bien à une
association qui s'est montrée ya
quelques années qui s'appelle le colosse
aux pieds d'argile qui a été monté par
sébastien boyer qui est un qui est un
colosse qui draine avec une carrière
dorée une canne carrure et une carrière
de rugbyman et qui a révélé avoir été
abusée entre ses 13 ans et ses 15 ans
avec d'autres de ses copains à
saint-paul-lès-dax dans un club de rugby
c'est qu'ils se sont regroupés en
association donc l'association le
colonel et d'argile et qui fait
maintenant beaucoup de prosélytisme et
beaucoup de beaucoup de présentations
dans les écoles dont les écoles de rugby
tous sports confondus maintenant de
manière à ce que ça n'arrive plus jamais
et surtout pour que les uns et les
autres s'organisent
même les plus jeunes même les plus
vulnérables pour parler pour parler et
dénoncer ça n'empêchera pas ce que vous
ce que vous ce que vous présentiez à
demi mot sur on va dire tous sur le sur
la calomnie et le fait de griller
quelqu'un sur un ballon ce ton port sans
autre forme de procès épreuve mais au
moins les vrais cas avérés seront seront
mises seront mis aux mises en lumière
est encore une fois pour que ça n'arrive
plus jamais exclu que ce puits que c'est
que ces gens là puissent être mis hors
d'état de nuire
je crois que c'est ça l'enjeu finalement
c'est d'arriver à ce que les générations
alors malheureusement ceux qui parlent
maintenant sont déjà un peu sacrifié
psychologiquement physiquement on le
sait ça c'est des séquelles qui restent
mais parler ça peut aussi être utile aux
générations qui viennent et je pense que
justement ce type d'association peux que
leur dire
un but mais d'utilité publique qui
consiste à libérer la parole de l'enfant
il a démontré que aujourd'hui ces
pratiques n'ont plus lieu d'être
en tout cas au moins dans le dos a
espéré que la révélation
oui de ces scandales va entraîner soit
ensuite couvert tant que c'est ça c'est
ça l'idée que saluer la personne bonne
chose je reviens l'ajustement des
prescriptions est ce qu'il n'ya pas
l'idée que dans les crimes sexuels ou la
prescription de parc de la majorité des
victimes
alors oui ça dépend aussi du moment où a
eu lieu l'événement dont elle fait la
prescription n'est pas calculé on
présente souvent ça comme un délai
automatique c'est pas vrai 1 ça dépend
évidemment du cac mais malheureusement
pour des délits qui ont lieu dans
l'enfance ou d'adolescents sont
aujourd'hui des femmes par mais
évidemment le délai prescrit les le
problème c'est aussi celui de la preuve
c'est à dire que généralement un violent
quand il a été dénoncé dans les
prochaines heures on doit avoir des
certaines graisses physique de violence
etc visant alors que moi là c'est le
problème de l' enquête aussi quand vous
parlez plus tard trop tard
il n'y a plus aucun moyen d'être à part
dans le face à face de parole dans
quelque chose de plus concret là comme
aux sorties parce que c'est un vrai
problème parce que disait jean faire
lorsque vrai c'est à dire que ces
dénonciations
voilà ce sont aussi dangereuses mais
comment arbitrer entre le le besoin de
paroles quand même et la dénonciation
dangereuse
c'est vrai qu'on est dans un bain on a
cantonné aux principes qui sont
totalement contradictoires
enfin la libération de la parole est
nécessaire et la présomption d'innocence
est aussi des scènes où nous vivons
quand même dans un pays merveilleux
conte beaucoup de gens disent qu'une
justice peut être lente mais efficace
qui existe qui donne la parole qui
enquêtent une police qui peut faire son
boulot on n'est pas dans une une
une souris public aux quelque chose donc
arrêtons aussi de de vouloir sur réagir
dès qu'il ya le moindre livre vaut vous
procès vaut condamnation jeudi on sort
un livre et hop ça y est c'est terminé
ben non c'est pas terminé et je veux
dire il faut qu'il faut que les enquêtes
se fasse et il faut qu'on puisse arrêter
ce déferlement avec ces journalistes qui
s'érige en procureur jean-yves la
dernière fois sur sur france inter sarah
abitbol qui dit je ne peux pas dire je
n'ai pas le droit de dire le nom du type
qui m'a agressé et léa salamé en espèces
de leurs grandes procureurs new style
qu'il y avait moi je vais le dire est
qu'il répète quatre fois de suite le nom
du type 2 qui est tel pour se permettre
un truc pareil c'était aller là mais
c'est ce sont les nouveaux juges
c'est totalement déprimant silésie léa
salamé c'est parangon de la justice on
peut tous l'ip est un jeune homme et ses
terres on a perdu le sens commun
je suis un peu d'accord je pense qu'on
libère la parole mais finalement plus
dans le bon cénacle c'est à dire que
maintenant ce sont les médias oui oui
alors comment en parler à un juge un
policier à caveirac sens et enquêter sur
un cas on a quelque chose d'un peu plus
impartial et au moins d'influx équitable
avec les droits de la défense mais
toujours ce problème de la prescription
ce problème aussi peut-être des méthodes
de la justice qui faisait que pendant
longtemps elle n'entendait pas ces cas
où elles ne donnaient pas une
satisfaction équitable avec des procès
qui était oui parce qu'on leur dit vous
savez tous à la cuisine elle qui a bien
démontré seul vous pouvez la prob mais
elles n'étaient pas entendues
mambé ça quand même donc on parle au
mauvais endroit à mon avis parce que les
réseaux sociaux maintenant sont devenus
une forme de gigantesque poubelle un
défouloir à tous les plus bas instincts
et malheureusement aux causes les plus
justes aussi donc est-ce qu'il ne
vaudrait mieux pas réformer un petit peu
les hoquets les mentalités mais parler
aux bons interlocuteurs qui sont les
juges et pas les médias et je pense
qu'on fera le parallèle tout à l'heure
avec mila la question est dans quelle
société vit-on aujourd'hui nos jeunes
nos enfants nos politiques négocié des
traités sur twitter enfin comment
peut-on continuer à vivre comme ça ça ça
moi ça m'angoisse ici on vient au quai
du sport un petit peu plus particulier
c'est que c'est que maintenant c'est au
moins des fédérations il y a une il ya
une prise de conscience puisqu'il faut
bien vous dire la nommer comme ça qu'ils
jouent à tous les tous les niveaux et
tout le monde amateur professionnel et
dans le sport dans tous les sports par
exemple il ya une une organisation qui
désormais descend vers les clubs
amateurs
pour prendre l'exemple que je connais
maintenant
celui d'al celui de la direction d'un
club de rugby versailles lors du
rugby-club versailles gagne à la
discrétion du président du président
d'association désormais il peut doit
demander un extrait de casier judiciaire
des encadrants des dirigeants et de ce
qui entraîne toutes les catégories de ce
soient les catégories seniors les
catégories jeunes ça tout le monde c'est
tout le monde se bat ciblées liées
puisque de toute façon c'est une serre
un acte simple et là qui se fait sur ce
qui se fait sur le web
donc il y à 7,10 à cette prise de
conscience générale qui amène les
consciences à changer et à vérifier
finalement à vérifier débusquera
peut-être c'est je crois que la
fédération française de foot qui a lancé
un test avec le partage du fichier
judiciaire des auteurs d'infractions
sexuelles est un croisement avec les
fichiers de licence
vous m'avez de rendre la licence quand
il donc ça c'est assez c'est assez
innovant et c'est assez inédit et en
croisant tous là ça cause ça concerne
évidemment des milliers de licenciés en
france un cas a été débusqué mais ça
suffit ça suffit pour mettre en place ce
système administratif qui est finalement
pas trop compliqué à mettre en place par
les responsabilités versailles
comment vous avez discuté évidemment
avec d'autres responsables comme ans et
vécut cesser ces révélations longtemps
cessé ce qui vient de se ré de
tremblement de terre c'est alors c'est
pas non plus je pense que c'est ce qu'on
découvre aussi peut-être mais on est
mieux confie c'est une surprise pour la
pour la plupart le la plupart des
encadrants évidemment côté versailles
c'est une c'est je pense un moyen de
montrer au contraire de vraiment de
prendre à l'inversé un contre-pied total
de montrer à quel point notre formation
est bien encadré pour le bien-être et la
performance de nos jeunes
on ad on a des enfants à l'école de
rugby qui vont de 2 5 6 ans jusqu'aux
jusqu'aux vétérans que je représente a
plus de 35 ans
justement prendre le contre-pied et dire
évidemment pas de ça chez nous on
vérifie malgré tout de manière de
manière administrative que c'est bien le
cas j'ose espérer non j'en suis sûr de
ne pas avoir de mauvaises surprises
mais en tout cas prendre le contre-pied
de pouvoir de pouvoir montrer à quel
point la formation est encadrée scène et
pour le bien-être de tous les enfants et
de tous les jeunes et les jeunes adultes
qui nous sont confiés oui parce que le
pire quand même des conséquences que
pourraient avoir ces affaires ça serait
que les parents au doute c'est pour ça
qu'il faut il faut juifs ont donné voilà
des garanties dans l'os le plus vite
possible ces quelques cas ignoble de
manière à ce que on puisse reparler de
sport reparler de performance et
reparler de reparler du bien-être du
bien et des jeunes et du sport santé en
général et mettre de côté malgré tout je
pense que les nombreux cac qui qui ne
manqueront pas de mon compagnon pense
que ça voilà oui parce que il faut pas
oublier ça c'est quand même c'est quand
même des valeurs le sport c'est camus
qui disent que ce qu'ils avaient appris
auprès de concéder au foot qu'il avait
appris c'est quand même ça la surprise
est d'autant plus grande
vous le saurez vous citiez tout à
l'heure elle a justement cette ces cas
qui vont qui vont émerger qui vont
émerger qui vont sortir du silence
c'est avant tout des grandes surprises
pour le milieu du sport et c'est parfois
même ces valeurs qui peuvent faire que
le scandale ne remonte pas justement
parce qu'il faut bien conscience de la
généralisation de la chose en disant
maintenant dans ce club il n'ya que des
agressions et des viols
du coup ça peut créer un système pervers
qui qui qui fait le scandale n'aboutit
pas qu'on a étouffé le
ce combat pendant sept ans exactement
fait le tour de ce sujet vous êtes dacca
au prochain scandale
olive fait parler d'elle puisque dit que
c'est assez proche s'est passé c'est un
peu la polémique parce que on voit bien
que la france est partagée sur ce sujet
est-ce qu'on peut n'a le droit au
blasphème ou pas c'est la polémique de
la semaine alors la ferme il a rappelé
tout à fait valable on en a parlé la
dernière foire n'ont cessé cette pauvre
jeune fille banques et qu'ils discutent
sur internet un groupe groupes de parole
un type un peu lourd essaye de d'entamer
une conversation plus plus sexuel que
qu'anodine et 7000 à lui dit gentiment
mais franchement gentiment écoute c'est
gentil mais c'est pas mon truc
brisons là on m'arrête et là un
déferlement de haine de la part de ce
type qui la traite en direct de sales
et le truc démarrer l bon
effectivement et se fait traiter de sale
wind elle répond écoute ta religion de
merde je la déteste et le prophète je
lui met un doigt dans le cul bon c'est
extrêmement un dédicaces et pas c'est
pas beau c'est pas c'est pas correct et
idiot hockey est ce que ça vous met
déferlement condamnation est ce que ça
vaut condamnation à mort et surtout
est-ce que ça vaut le silence de tout et
je dis bien de toutes les associations
féministes qui pour l'instant en
impression que milla est un homme c'est
à dire que les associations féministes
hooper visiblement de s'attaquer à ce
problème de religion est déjà paru alors
elle a dit du mal de l'islam alors là on
la reconnaît plus en tant que femme on
ne se prête on la défend pas en deux
c'est totalement des membres et des
paroles un peu ambigu et de la garde des
sceaux ou des paroles condamnant tu
ségolène royal entre nicole belloubet
ségolène royal allait faire d'abord un
point juridique sur le droit au
blasphème il existe il n'existe pas
alors il n'existe pas de droit au
blasphème est en réalité n'existe pas de
blasphème donc déjà au mans c'est à dire
quand on réellement m c'est cette idée
donc de critiquer ou de se moquer une
religion mais ça n'a aucun fondement
juridique ça en avait 1 jusqu'à 2017 en
droit alsaciens mosellans mais qui n'a
déjà tout à fait particulier et qui a
été en plus abrogée parce qu'il était
tombé en désuétude depuis 1912 il a été
abrogée en 2010 c'est donc on n'a pas de
fondement dans le code pénal d'un délit
de blasphème et c'est normal parce qu'on
veut séparer endroit l'état et n'importe
quelle législation de la religion
d'accord face à cela une fois qu'on a
dit ça en réalité on n'a pas dit grand
chose c'est pour ça que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a eu
plusieurs fois à se prononcer sur des
caricatures des dessins des écrivains
des des paroles des spectacles qui ont
pu avoir lieu et critiquer la religion
critiquer la religion c'est comme
critiquer n'importe quel autre cénacle
pour la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme ça doit se faire dans le respect
sur un ton humoristique ou sur un ton
polémique pour lancer un débat ça ne
doit pas mener à ce qu'on appelle des
incitations à la haine mais ça c'est un
délit purement français qu'on a dans
notre loi sur la liberté de la presse de
1881 parce que religion et ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est que la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme était
assez libérale pendant très longtemps et
que l'année dernière où il ya à peu près
18 mois dans un arrêt contre l'autriche
elle a pu reconnaître qu'on pouvait
aller trop loin dans la critique des
religions et elle a donc certains
juristes 10 consacré le délit de
blasphème mais c'est pas du tout le cas
mais elle a en effet qu dit je crois une
association pour avoir été un petit peu
trop loin dans la critique de religion
donc c'est vrai que le curseur est assez
délicat a fixé ici
ce qui pourrait aller dans l'incitation
à la haine dans ce cas la fessée le
public auquel elle avait à faire c'est à
dire que ça s'est pas passé dans un
cénacle privé ça s'est fait sur des
réseaux donc du coup il ya un côté un
peu médiatique on va dire un phénomène
de groupe mais incitation à la haine
s'est pas totalement en corrélation non
plus avec ce cas la vie donc c'est assez
compliqué sa précision pas droit juste
parce que c'est intéressant quand même
il me semblait mois qu'on pouvait
critiquer les religions et pas les pas
les pratiquants c'est à dire que il ya
eu par exemple quand on voit le bac a
dit l'islam et la pluie ou la religion
la plus con qui existe il n'a pas été
condamné
quand brigitte bardot a dit les
musulmans sont des sauvages
elle a été condamnée mais d'un côté il y
avait une religion qui était attaquée de
l'eau des pratiquants sks qui est ce
qu'il ya sept
effectivement c'est vraiment cette
dichotomie qui fait dire que denis
auguin
c'est à dire en fait on peut critiquer
des principes des idées mais des
idéologies pas les gens mais on peut pas
critiquer directement des personnels
évidemment une fois qu'on a dit c'est la
présence la distinction a ses limites
puisque critiquer une religion c'est
incidemment critiqué ceux qui la
pratiquent si on fait une généralité qui
étaient là des propos offensants
donc ces épisodes commandés ça c'était
les principes juridiques après il ya une
analyse politique voulait régler le ski
ce qui est étonnant de noter et on en
parlait sur le sujet précédent
c'est cette tribune cette nouvelle
tribune des tribus ceux des réseaux
sociaux qui qu'il a aussi à son à son
lot et son déferlement de parole et ses
cellules au départ c'est du contextuel
ça reste du domaine privée
ces échanges là que vous que vous
rappeliez
et puis derrière et à ce déferlement
parce que parce qu'on attaque l'islam
son attaque cette religion là parce que
finalement elle n'a pas visé les autres
donc on part on part d'instinct d'un
phénomène assez générique mais
spécifique sur la religion musulmane est
derrière de tout y passe sont ses
préférences sexuelles
la personne qu'elle est elle même et
puis et puis désormais il ya maintenant
je pense que du côté juridique il ya à
priori de la justice hésite également
parce qu'il ya deux leviers de deux
affaires qui vont monkey vont sortir et
de condamner phase de recherche de
condamnations qui vont sortir d'un côté
et ses débuts ce qu'il est les hauteurs
de déchets ménagers et des propos des
propos pour harcèlement et incitation au
meurtre d'un côté et elle l'a eue
l'autre en dix ans cette incitation à la
haine raciale
7le par kbc cette drôle d'idée et puis
finalement de deux ans de l'atelier
parce que je rappelle quand même une
chose par les réseaux sociaux en dix ans
et on n'est pas dans le domaine privé
alors que pensez-vous de frédéric
froment qui sur france inter qui ne
paraît pas être une radio microscopiques
et confidentielles se permet entre 17 et
18 ans la plus grosse écoute à la radio
à cette heure-là surtout toutes chaînes
confondues qui se permet une chanson
très drôle en disant jésus était jésus
est un jésus et il a été cloué
sur la croix on aurait mieux fait de
l'anc eu les bons il entendu est-ce
qu'on entende une à missane a suscité
strictement aucune réaction c'est à dire
que c'est à dire que la prise de risque
de le bourhis en question et les nuggets
ont proposé ces deux critères
la réponse est dans l'action que vous
avez c'est que vous avez parlé d'un
humoriste
donc il est déjà pas dans les mêmes
catégories légale qu'elle merci
l'humoriste après ça veut dire qu'en
réalité il y en a 6 degrés alors que l
alors la question c'est celle du degré
aussi parce qu'on voit bien et comme tu
le dis qu'elle réplique encore il est
déjà dans quelque chose qui l'a énervé
nos jeunes alors soit dit en passant
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être un moment
aussi pour dire quelles violences des
deux côtés quand même la jeunesse qui
vit à l'épaule n'est pas tant à cause
d'un seul côté
alors elle reste quand même très
durement
je me permettrai même pas de reprendre
les propos tellement j'étais un petit
peu un petit peu gras de du côté adverse
on a des menaces de mort et si c'était
la seule à vivre ça ça serait même déjà
dramatique mais ça n'est absolument pas
le cas on parle de deux jeunes qui se
suicident en raison des maux qui voit
apparaître sur sur leurs réseaux moi je
trouve que c'est vraiment ça déjà le
premier cas c'est arrêtons de se parler
sur ce ton là à ces âges là on est
fragile on se cherche on a cherché sur
son orientation sexuelle sur sa manière
de se présenter
on va trop loin il faudrait peut-être
essayer de reprendre des choses à zéro
sur les réseaux se parler correctement
et censuré sur les coteaux il aurait pu
mais je ne comprends pas comment des
commentaires comme ça peuvent prospérer
il ya forcément il ya l'associé de
modération il ya sept premiers points
après il ya les réactions il ya un
sondage qui montre que les français sont
des vidéos 50 % disent oui on peut
critiquer les religions 50% pensent que
non et puis il ya des intérieurs sont
des politiques intervention très
étonnante de ségolène royal dans ses
habits sont là sont lassants tellement
en recherche d'une nouvelle un nouvel
auditoire d'une nouvelle
la nouvelle électorat qui effectivement
elle est prête à enfourcher à peu près
n'importe quel cheval
elle a condamné très nettement c'est
stupéfiant enfin je veux dire cette
femme qui était quand même à une époque
tout à fait sensé qui était à la pointe
de de combat tout à fait intelligent
contre le bizutage fin déclic avant vous
analysez votre ami des traits de
l'événement mais dd très grand pas qui
mais là on se dit mais quelle folie la
saisie alors j'étais gêné quand même un
pendant qu'elle répond sans moi je suis
d'accord avec la nouvelle ségolène
canton tu parles c'est à dire que pour
ça que tous avec benoît sincère mais la
question il ya aussi le traitement il
yal'affaire il ya le traitement de l'air
qui biaise un petit peu les choses parce
que c'est quelque chose qui est repris
par les médias et qui d'ailleurs un
moment l affaire commencé à s'éteindre
et voyez qu'un jour après on en reparle
encore parce que les médias
interroge les politiques et avec cette
question qui en fait bies complètement
la réflexion etes-vous milhoud n'êtes
vous pas mis l'art et la manière de
présenter le débat est complètement
folle et la question n'est pas reprise
alors qu'en réalité je crois qu'on est
globalement à peu près tous d'accord
pour dire que la liberté d'expression à
tout le moins si on est républicain que
la liberté la règle et la restriction
l'exception alors évidemment cette cette
liberté on n'est pas dans un état
totalitaire c'est à dire qu'on peut dire
des conneries on peut même comment
dirais-je insulté dans une certaine
mesure sans tomber complètement sous le
coup de la loi
ça me parait ça me paraît sensé et puis
dans le même temps on est tous d'accord
pour dire que on n'a pas insulté on n'a
pas injurier on n'a pas à généraliser et
qu'il faut avoir un petit peu de
subtilité donc dire être vous milhoud
n'êtes vous pas mis là c'est ne pas voir
la double face du problème et du coup
c'est insisté sur un élément à faire que
l'autre peut prendre pour vrai ce qui en
fait est pensé autrement part favori
mais battu c'est pas du tout
c'est pas du tout ce que ça veut dire
parce que là vous dites on n'en parlait
plus on en parle plus peut-être on
aurait pu ne plus en parler mais enfin
mis là elle est toujours exclue de son
collège enfin exclu de fortes neiges
il est scolarisé à domicile on est en
train de voir comment on peut changer
son nom parce qu'elle ne peut plus aller
nulle part
les choses allaient rechercher des
réseaux sociaux avec justement ces
absences de nuances c'est insensé
presque manichéen c'est à dire vous
devez dire on est absolument vous êtes
pour vous d'être contre eux qui a acheté
que je suis vois ça que je ne suis pas
c'est seulement il ya plus aucune gêne
possible et je suis persuadé que tous
autour de la table on n'a pas un avis
tranché sur la question parce que il n'y
a peut-être raté du pour et du contre à
chaque analyse et un petit peu plus sauf
que c'est tellement et on est sommé de
d'être pour ou contre c'est elle se met
d'être blanc noir et blanc ce n'est pas
le maître des premiers échanges dont
vous que vous voyez ça a été tellement
violent c'était tellement rapide que le
déferlement derrière et doit être
adressée en étant pour ou contre
oui mais on est tous d'accord pour dire
que les paroles de millas sont
grotesques et choquante et provocante
mais l'accord de même que frédéric
flamand sur france inter mais la
question n'est pas là la question est ce
qu'on a le droit de dire les choses et
surtout est ce qu'on a le droit de
laisser qu'une fille condamnée à mort
par peuple sa part des gens c'est clair
éléments il va danser bien avec les
guests il est pas dans les boules de
mila il est dans le fait que des gens ça
arrange rien a dit ça ça nous plaît pas
on la condamne à mort on lui interdit
d'en mais en misant ces questions vous
voyez bien que rien vous introduisez
déjà un des nuances donc c'est vrai que
là on n'ait sommet d'être pourront tout
laonnois d'avoir une position absolue
alors que les affaires sont souvent plus
compliqué que ça c'est vrai je suis pour
la liberté
on peut je crois quand même que les
réseaux sociaux ont une responsabilité
cependant ces affaires là notamment
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'identité sur sur
ses réseaux et c'est pour ça que
finalement on peut être mis là on ne pas
être mis là parce qu'on n'est pas
recherchée dernière n'y a pas de
conséquence à la parole alors que si
aujourd'hui
la pauvre mines en subit les
conséquences mais tout le monde doit
comprendre que ce qu'on dit sur ces
réseaux lan et pas ça ne ce n'est pas
une poubelle les gens les reçoivent
et on a des adolescents qui se suicident
à cause de ça je le redis mais moi je
trouve qu'on est vraiment ici dans le
coeur d'une polémique qui est
intéressante sur comment les réseaux
sociaux peuvent arriver à mettre fin à
ce type de discours et à censurer à
modérer à trouver des éléments pour
qu'en tout cas l'identité puisse être
connue et pour qu'on puisse agir si ces
réseaux sociaux sont des tribunaux
qu'ils agissent comme des tribunaux
allemands puis relativisons si les
choses là on n'est pas face à deux
adultes type minam sur un débat qui va
être préparé gamin créer du buzz
là on a deux adolescents qui d'ailleurs
le premier en plus tu as quand même jugé
aussi très sévèrement son identité
sexuelle par rapport à l'islam en disant
qu'elle et lui brûler en enfer et donc
par rapport à ça
elle critique la religion chacun est
dans l'outrance deux adolescents qui
n'ont pas cette chance elle a raison de
dire c'est qu'elle est menacée de mort
qui sait qu'elle peut plus aller glisser
sur voilà bien sûr c'est ça c'est non
mais pour relativiser la porte
habituellement la porte de sa wii ça
s'est passé un débat de gamins et toute
la france est obligée de prendre parti
voilà votre grossesse
alors on continue avec une autre société
vachement bien réseaux sociaux audi vise
les bas formidable sur le congé parental
quand quand on est une famille perd un
enfant
eh ben c'est le débat de la semaine mais
ça on a l'impression d'être un pur
réalisme dire quand on quand on aborde
ces sujets c'est à dire quand même on va
quand même un peu mal non oui quand on
non mais quand vous regardez du sujet et
vie
qui dit ville c'est vrai que le fait de
le traiter tous ensemble et tous s'en
sortent mais malheureusement il ya aussi
des victimes faut pas l'oublier et
quelles qu'elles soient et quel que soit
le niveau essais mais c'est vrai c'est
une vraie question sur l'état de notre
société l'état psychologique
sociologique des bonus les français ont
battu les anglais
oui avec les raisons de se réjouir
c'est vrai quel nom il y avait le bras
qui avait écrit un livre qui était
comment se sentir mal dans une france
qui va bien quoi il ya aussi ce
pessimisme ambiant qui inquiétait mais
parlons un peu de cette polémique sur le
le congé parental
en effet les députés avaient demandé
l'allongement du congé parental aucune
perte d'un enfant opposition ne finisse
du travail qui dit c'est pas aux
entreprises de faire de l'humanitaire
serveurs aux entreprises de payer ça
évidemment ça va engendrer une polémique
et plenel d'hickstead une ignominie par
exemple que madame pénigaud soit pas la
plus grande communicante et leur
certains pensent que sans ce que l'art
peut faire ça c'est un autre certes l
unanimité
donc là disons pour rendre la messe est
dite
ok de ce côté là après je supplie de
reconnaître pour une fois que vous allez
me rappeler son jeu l'oubli ça fait un
acte manqué l'éditorialiste politique de
france inter un bon enfin bref ça va
nous revenir qui lui même disait mais
c'est un c'est un débat d'une extrême
malhonnêteté et il accuse effectivement
je n'attendais edwy plenel de l'immeuble
d'ignominies pas ce qu'il dit les
députés ont simplement et là le grand
thomas legrand thomas legrand voilà qui
normalement à la limite de l'extrême
ghoul qui est toujours à tirer à boulet
rouge sur tout ce qui vient du
gouvernement ce serait parce qu'il ya le
mot goût de dents à la robe tout ils
attaquent mais là c'est lui qui vient
l'arsb hdi des députés est il bien l'art
ce qu elle à la rescousse des députés
dans marchandises ans ils se sont juste
placé sur un truc parce que le taux qui
était mal ficelé juridiquement et qu' il
allait aller dans le mur et que c'était
pas du tout comme ça qu'il fallait faire
et lui même dit mais on peut pas
soupçonner un seul instant n'importe
aucun député dans mars ou de quels que
soient leur probablement une faute de
communication c'est une énorme somme et
de location et les députés s'étaient
retranchés des reins des des arguties
juridiques et voilà je pense qu'il faut
rockets replacer la salade su mon mai
là on peut douter de cela c'est que le
président de république est intervenu
dans ce débat pour demander à la
majorité de faire preuve d'humanité
oui ça donne à croire qu'on n'est pas
dans l'erreur il est alors il ya une
erreur dans les hommes enfin parce que
j'ai plus confiance et des remparts les
mains je pense que du moment en ce
moment on entend peu maniable mâcon
quand on entend peut-être un moment où
il aurait pu aussi se taire parce
qu'effectivement l histoire de se tirer
une balle dans le clip se met tous ses
députés contre soi en disant moquer
d'humanité fond dans la nullité fiche
cela dit je cite pardon excusez moi
denis tillinac qui sort un dictionnaire
de gaulle et dans une interview et dc
macron votre élu il faut que l'iss il
faut qu'ils se séparent du maquereau 10
mhz donc c'est peut-être qu'il est tout
autre le premier atelier paraît bien
parti emmanuel macron répondez lui même
au début de polémique
oui il ya aussi avec un sujet sur les
réseaux sociaux et qui avait débuté par
françois ruffin je crois que c'est le
transport sur le ficelage juridique
rapidement ce qui s'est passé c'est
qu'en réalité il ya déjà une disposition
sur le congé parental pour deuil de
l'enfant qui devait être rallongée il y
avait deux amendements sur cet article
qui demandait où je crois 48 heures de
réflexion et c'est sur les indemnités en
plus est en réalité on avait gardé que
les deux amendements en supprimant la
dispositions initiales la part une
erreur et donc du coup quand on est
arrivés sur la discussion de la
maintenant il n'y avait plus la dea le
dispositif général non c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont été un double dans l'angoissé
en disant mais 48 heures c'est plus
suffisant on était censé être dans les
48 heures sur douze jours donc il ya un
problème technique ce sur quoi muriel
pénicaud a ensuite enchaîné en disant
oui mais finalement c'est tout le
dispositif qui méritait de tomber mais
en réalité c'est vrai qu'au départ c'est
parti d'un espèce de petit caprice âge
de discussion qui convient de retracer
la chose que sadi de la cinquième risque
voilà de la vème république c'est qu'on
avait affaire sous de gaulle à des
députés qu'on qualifiait de députés
godillots dans le sens où l on leur
aurait donné à voter n'importe quoi ils
allaient suivre leur majorité
ici on a vraiment la preuve de cela
c'est à dire que malheureusement
l'assemblée nationale c'est quand même
censé être le lieu du débat public dont
même quand on est dans la majorité on
est censé quand même pouvoir ouvrir ses
oreilles et ici on a vraiment la
démonstration d'une discipline de parti
tellement forte que dès lors qu'on a me
dire quelque chose d'idiot
le groupe évidemment suis et je crois
que c'est là dessus qu'ils se sont un
peu ridiculisé
il ya cette lecture là qui est élections
politiques que vous faites
il ya une lecture sociologique qu'on
peut faire et même économique
est ce que la loi de l'entreprise et pas
en train de s'imposer partout on
reproche déliera macron à sa majorité de
gérer la france comme une entreprise
avec des règles de l'entreprise
et c'est vrai qu'il ya des lois de
l'entreprise qui est à lire de dépenser
le moins possible de faire le plus de
bénéfices possibles
est ce que c'est parce a au fond qu
reproche à cette majorité à ce
gouvernement fière d'être trop pâle
écoute de l'économie je crois qu'ils
adhéraient perdre de peu perdu peut-être
un peu l'humanité et qui qui va aussi
dans le nécessaire aussi quand on
gouverne je crois que la question
politique et lee justement à cette
question économique c'est à dire qu'on
avait effectivement un parlement
godillot plutôt au début de la vème
république
mais ça c'est un petit peu perdues quand
même c'est à dire que cette idée de fait
majoritaire on a une sous sarkozy sous
landes des majorités qui quand même sur
des sujets importants prenaient leurs
distances modifier les choses
bon là effectivement on retombe dans les
travers tout le temps qu'on peut aussi
appeler une chambre d'enregistrement
août mais je crois que ça ça tient
justement profil de ces parlementaires
qui sont non pas des politiques mais qui
sont pour l'essentiel issus de la
société civile et je crois que c'est ça
qui explique qu'ils n'ont pas aussi
cette conscience politique de s'imposer
et qui qu'ils ont plutôt ce réflexe qui
est le leur qui est un club vote
écologiste qui sont des bons techniciens
dans leur domaine mais qui vont plutôt
avoir un réflexe de la société civile et
de se dire je vais faire ce que je sais
faire et quand je sais pas
j'y vais et puis ce que je sais faire
c'est par exemple des interventions qui
vont consister à dire que du point de
vue des entreprises s'est pas
l'entreprise de le faire et d'avoir ce
discours là je crois que les deux
questions sont liées et on peut
regretter aussi qu'il n'y ait pas cette
cette culture politique aussi d'aider
des parlementaires on pensait qu'ils
allaient le l'acquérir justement cette
culture assez rapidement et on se rend
compte que c'est pas le cas je trouve
que c'est plutôt dommage que ça veut
dire
il ya un fil rouge dans les trois sujets
convient d'évoquer c'est l'aspect
communication et l'instantané parler des
réductions parler des réseaux sociaux
sur les deux premiers les deux premiers
sujets c'est peut-être un peu moins le
cas enfin même carrément moins le cas
ici on ne reviendra pas effectivement
sur le sur la maîtrise des dossiers de
muriel pénicaud etc les couacs à
répétition justement lorsque lorsqu'elle
est fébrile sur un sur un sujet et là
c'est la bombe a été lâchée et sur le
sur la présentation ne serait-ce que de
l'étude à l'assemblée nationale de ce
projet et les les interprétations quand
on fait certains ministres ont achevé en
effet ce ce projet cette consultation
finalement dans le feu mais moi je crois
surtout une chose c'est juste moi j'y
crois pas du tout au fait qu'on est dans
cet esprit de l'entreprise face à
l'humanité c'est comme un geyser bien
parce que c'est quand même à des
reproches qu'on fait si le pouvoir
actuel faut s'obliger nahles que même
les entreprises n'auraient pas pu si
celles ci avaient été les grands patrons
qu'ils avaient voté oui ce serait passé
à l'unanimité non moi je ne crois pas
une seconde au fait qu'on oppose la loi
de l'humanité à la loi de l'économie
parce que les deux peuvent largement
s'entendre heureusement ans vit en
démocratie mais la seule chose qui moi
me dérange et je pense que la faute de
communication en a commise
bien plus tard quand les députés se sont
dits prêts à revoter dans un sens
différent et là je crois qu'on
ridiculise complètement notre assemblée
nationale le processus et voire même le
courage politique c'est à dire que si le
dispositif n'était pas le bon et que la
ministre a tenté s'y opposer reprenons à
zéro ou alors disons eh bien non c'est
parce que ce dispositif était mal ficelé
et qu'on n'en veut pas voilà
dans l'autre c'est exactement ça donne
dans les stations ça prouve aussi que
c'est donc ils n'ont pas dit si en même
temps moi c'est ça qui me gêne c'est
qu'on n'ose pas forcément décider
quelque chose et là en plus on a un
président qui est un peu mis en minorité
avec les retraites et qui essaye de se
faire aimer en partant de l'autre côté
ça c'est un peu dangereux et l'esprit de
gaulle c'était vraiment de trancher dans
le vif et d'y aller une bonne fois pour
tout je crois que ça manque un peu à nos
politiques en ce mec comme quand je
parlais de cette mainmise de l'économie
sur la question des retraites c'est bien
ça aussi vous reproche au pouvoir
si ça devient compliqué cession
d'actions et des visions économiques
vision même financier un ancien oui
c'est un sujet économique
heureusement la finition des retraites
c'est moi sur mes skis
est ce qu'une réforme de retraite des
rallyes
justement vous parliez de vous parliez
de la confrontation au fond de ses
ministres et finalement au suffrage
universel ya une polémique sur sur le
premier ministre qui se présente à la
mairie du havre
certains disent on peut pas être premier
ministre et se présenter aux élections
municipales d'autres disent au contraire
un ben voila se confronter au terrain et
c'est bien qu'est ce que vous en prof
les jetons quoi on a déjà des polémiques
contribue l'intérêt mais leurs larmes
ravi des sommets attaqué jouer mais je
ne serai pas le maire parce que je
reviens à matignon sont inquiets
on se doute bien que veut pas être maire
du havre et premier ministre bon donc là
ya pas de polémique le dire on peut pas
faire les deux donc qu'ils se présentent
d'autres fois ça existait un savant
était maire de bordeaux me semble-t-il
ici juppé a aussi été ajouté le ministre
aucun autre époque c'est quand même
mieux que vous alors saisi ça veut dire
qu'on fait rien la mairie de bordeaux où
on fait rien matignon enfin j'veux dire
si on peut faire les deux tranquillement
ça me paraît plus du tout d'actualité
enfin il ya quand même pas la même pas
lieu de débattre je dirais que la droite
se présenter c'est une personnalité il
est nommé est ce que c'est bien
justement tueur confronté servi dieu
problème quand on compte en parler du
cumul des mandats justement les
adversaires de plus il demande à 10 m et
si vous interdisez le cumul des mandats
ça veut dire qu'ils vont être hors sol
tous ses députés qu'il a aussi loin
aussi ses difficultés ou un problème un
problème de présentation et de
communication
ça arrive finalement dans au sein d'un
quinquennat qui prône le non cumul des
mandats et concrètement si je me
présentais c'est peut-être pour plus
tard c'est reculer pour mieux sauter et
récupérer les balles du havre après son
mandat à matignon
mais ça laisse ça laisse la possibilité
de penser qu'on pourrait faire les deux
et a priori il ya suffisamment à faire à
matignon en ce moment pour mais pas pour
ne pas troubler trouve élections et la
communication sur une mairie de mairie
du havre
en plus c'est relativement courageux
parce que on peut aussi penser que la
personnalité riche
2 edouard philippe c'est trop de risques
est venue du meneur des havrais le débit
du gouvernement pourrait tout à fait
faire qu'ils font un score bien en deçà
de 6 donc c'est courageux alors
puisqu'il nous reste à peu près une
minute et vous qu'on va vous dire sur 1
on vous en parlait la victoire avec
l'île de france face à l'angleterre oui
que cebu que c'est bon et puis
évidemment face à nos meilleurs ennemis
anglais ctv proville la catalogne et
bella ont toujours pour parler de
communication c'est l'arroseur arrosé
ouais assez long et 10 jones qui promet
la foudre à nos jeunes joueurs français
et qui c'est qui s'est retrouvée qui
s'est retrouvé vraiment dans la
tourmente et dans 1 dans un jeu on a
retrouvé aérer le french flair impôts de
retour la fougue de la jeunesse et au
meilleur moment parce que c'est le début
du cd v de v de galles - de galtier et
et consorts il ya vraiment une bonne
équipe derrière c'est là sur le papier
on le voit il est le réseau justement de
faire cela il a mis un coup de balai ça
fait ça fait ne serait-ce qu'une
quinzaine d'années qu'on attend ça c'est
à dire avant avant chaque avant chaque
coupe du monde de remettre les quatre
des cartes et puis de former ces joueurs
là pour le dans l'optique de la coupe du
monde en france en 2023 et oui on a une
très très bonne forme
on a des très bons jeunes des talents
ils l'ont prouvé dimanche et on l'espère
pour le reste du tournoi
voilà il n'y a pas que des scandales
dans le double dvd match qui nous
réjouit merci beaucoup
pierre chevallier merci beaucoup jean
baptiste duclair a observé mme vézina
duclair effet jean charles lajoie ni et
très bientôt un nouveau prof
[Musique]